aquí en la avenida de moles Avenida roja
que conecta al palacio de bucking con la
plaza trafalgar y por donde este sábado
pasará La carroza del Rey Carlos III y
la reina consorte Camila minutos antes
de que inicie oficialmente La era de
Carlos III con su coronación en la
abadía de Westminster se reúnen miles y
miles de personas que como ustedes
pueden ver a mis espaldas están
acampando incluso desde el lunes para
poder tener la primera vista de ese
momento histórico algunos han viajado
desde todos los puntos de Inglaterra
incluso desde el exterior para poder
presenciar minuto a minuto este momento
histórico que la mayoría de los
británicos no ha visto la última
coronación fue hace 70 años la de la
Reina Isabel segunda la madre del Rey
Carlos III para estas personas hubo un
momento de mucha felicidad esta tarde
cuando el Rey Carlos tercero bajó de su
carro por esta Avenida Roja de Mall
saludó algunas de las personas que se
encontraban Aquí también lo hicieron el
príncipe William y su esposa Kate
middleton a esta hora más de 100
representantes de diferentes gobiernos
asisten a una recepción ofrecida por el
Rey en el Palacio de buckingham y hacen
parte de esos 2.300 invitados que
presenciaran este momento histórico una
ceremonia que conservará las tradiciones
desde mil sesenta y seis pero que tendrá
toques de modernidad para adaptarlo a la
época en la que estamos viviendo de una
sociedad mucho más inclusiva por ejemplo
representantes religiosos de religiones
no cristianas harán parte de esa
ceremonia se considera que Londres es en
este momento una de las capitales por
supuesto más seguras por el inmenso
dispositivo de seguridad en el que
participan más de 11.500 uniformados
pero a también habrá por supuesto
medidas de seguridad en el espacio aéreo
de la capital británica porque se espera
que miles y miles de turistas no
solamente del Reino Unido sino del
exterior me gana la capital británica
para este momento también habrá
manifestaciones del grupo Republic que
busca que este país se convierta en una
república parlamentarista Y en Escocia
se adelantarán algunas manifestaciones
exigiendo un segundo referéndum de
independencia para que esta nación
Escocia pueda dejar el Reino Unido